let's talk about proportionality
proportion portion ality all this means
if we say that two variables are
proportional it just means that they are
constant multiples of each other so this
is so if we say that Y is equal to three
times X we can say that Y is and we can
be a little bit more specific we could
say Y is directly proportional Y is
directly directly proportional
proportional to X - X and of course we
could divide both sides of this equation
and we would by three and we would get
one-third Y is equal to X so once again
X is a constant multiple of Y we could
write this as X is equal to one-third Y
so we could also write that X is
directly directly proportional
proportional to Y if Y is directly
proportional to X then X is also
directly proportional to Y by a
different proportionality constant so
this term right here this is the
constant of proportionality between y
and X or between x and y this is the
constant of proportionality so in
general if I say if I say that a is
directly proportional directly sometimes
you'll just see it written as a is
proportional a is directly proportional
proportional to B in general from this
statement we could write we could write
that a is equal to some constant times B
where this constant is equivalent to
that constant or that constant it's
equal to some number and you could also
say that B is directly proportional to a
where you know if you divide both sides
of this equation by K you would get B is
equal to one over K a this is direct
proportionality now
another thing you might see and we'll
see it later in this video is being
inversely proportional so let me draw a
little line here let me draw a little
line here so let me give you a few
examples of inverse proportionality
let's say that Y is equal to 5 times 1
over X notice what's going on here in
this situation Y is proportional to the
inverse of X right or you could say that
Y is inversely in verse ly proportional
I'll just write I'll abbreviate it
proportional to X it is directly
proportional to the inverse of X so here
here is our proportionality constant but
it is directly proportional to the
inverse of X here's another example and
I'm just playing with letters here I
could write a is equal to 10 over B once
again a is inversely proportional to B
you could rewrite this as a is equal to
10 times 1 over B a is proportional to
the inverse of B or it's inversely
proportional to B so now that we have
that out of the way let's do some
examples using our our newly found
knowledge of direct proportionality and
inverse proportionality so here I have a
problem it says that X is proportional
to Y so we that means that X is equal to
some constant times y and just so you're
familiar with other notation that you
might see and when you're talking about
proportionality other ways to write this
statement here X is proportional to Y
you could write it like this X is equal
to some constant times y or you could
write it as X is proportional to Y that
little I don't know left-facing fish
looking thing means proportional this
and this mean the same thing this means
that X is equal
some constant times y or sometimes
you'll even see it X squiggly line y X
is equal to some constant times y this
this and this and that are all
equivalent statements but this is the
most useful you can say oh there's some
constant maybe we can solve for that
constant then the next statement here it
says X is proportional to Y and
inversely proportional to Z so that
second statement says that X is equal to
K let me it's going to be a different
constant not necessarily the same
constant so let me put a different well
I'll call it k2 I'll call this k1 is
equal to some other constant not
necessarily some other but I'm guessing
it's going to be some other constant
times the inverse of Z times 1 over Z
that's what inversely proportional to Z
means and other ways we could write this
is X is proportional to the inverse of Z
X is inversely proportional Z or X is
inversely proportional to Z these things
in orange are all equivalent I just want
to make you familiar with it in case you
ever see it and then they tell us they
tell us ok X is proportional to Y
inversely proportional Z we wrote that
already and X is equal to 2 when y is
equal to 10 so let's do that
X is equal to 2 when y is equal to 10 so
X is equal to 2 when k1 is multiplied by
Y that's what that statement tells us
and Y is 10 when k1 is x 10 X is 2 when
y is 10 I just put those numbers in
there and then we can actually use this
now to solve for K 1 but before that
let's see what this next statement tells
us it says x is 2 when y is 10 and Z is
25 so X is 2 X is 2 when k1 is
multiplied sorry
when k2 when k2 this k2 is multiplied by
1 over Z when multi
5 so that's what that second statement
tells us so they say find X when y is
equal to 8 and
z is equal to 35 so essentially what
they're asking us hey why don't you use
this information that we gave you in the
green and the red solve for the
different proportionality constants and
then use that to write I guess the
specific equations for the
proportionality or the inverse
proportionality and then solve for y or
Z let's just do it
so here up here in green let me rewrite
it over here we know that X is 2 when Y
when K 1 is multiplied by Y where Y is
10 divide both sides of this equation by
10 you get 2 over 10 is 1/5 you get K 1
is equal to 1/5 so that tells us that
this first equation right here I'll
write it in that original color is X is
equal to 1/5 Y now that second statement
in red we know that 2 2 is equal to K 2
times 1 over 25 let's multiply both
sides of this equation by 25 this
cancels out and we're left with K 2 K 2
is equal to 50 K 2 is equal to 50 so we
can write this equation right here that
X is equal to 50 times 1 over Z or is
equal to 50 over Z so we've now solved
for the two constants of proportionality
for these two equations so now we can
answer the second part of this question
find X when y is equal to 8 and Z is
equal to 35 so the situation when y is
equal to 8 we just go right here X is
equal to 1/5 times 8 which is equal to 8
over 5 so that's what X is equal to when
Y is equal to 8 when Z is equal to 35
once again X is equal to 50 over Z is
equal to 50 over 35 and let's see we can
divide the numerator and the denominator
here by 5 so we get 10 over 7 so when Z
is equal to 35 we get 10 over 7
in when Y is equal to 8 X is equal to 8
over 5 so those are our two answers
right there let's do another one
Ohm's law Ohm's law states that current
flowing in a wire is inversely
proportional to resistance of the wire
so current flowing in a wire is
inversely proportional to resistance of
a wire so let's use I for current I is
equal to current and we'll use R for
resistance R is equal to resistance and
you might be wondering why I picked I
but later on when you start studying
electricity and maybe you become an
electrical engineer you'll see that I is
the conventional letter used for current
and I won't go into the details of why
just yet
but it tells us that current that I is
inversely proportional to resistance so
that first statement I underlined in
yellow says that current is inversely
proportional it's equal to some constant
times the inverse of resistance is
inversely proportional to resistance of
the wire if the current is two point
five amperes when the resistance is
twenty ohms so the current is two point
five when K is multiplied by one over a
resistance of twenty ohms one over
twenty ohms and I'm assuming because
they're going to keep the units in
amperes and ohms later on so we could
write you know we could write em we
could write the unit's here if we want
to do but I'll keep it simple and not
write the unit's they ask find the
resistance when the current is 5 amperes
so this first statement right here the
current is two point five amperes when
the resistance is twenty ohms that's
this equation right here right here so
we can use this to solve for K you
multiply both sides of this by 20
multiply both sides of this by 20 these
cancel out and you're left with K is
equal to what's 20 times
2.5 20 times 2 is 40
times 0.5 is 10 so it's going to be 50
40 plus 10 so K is equal to 50 so in
this situation this equation is I I is
equal to 50 times 1 over R or 50 over R
that's our relationship right there and
then they ask find the resistance when
the current is 5 amperes find the
resistance when the current is 5 amperes
so when our current is 5 amperes so 5 is
equal to 50 over the resistance let's
multiply both sides of this equation by
the resistance and you get 5 R is equal
to 50 right I just multiplied both sides
of this equation by are these cancelled
out so I got 5 R is equal to 50 divide
both sides of this equation by 5 we get
R is equal to 50 divided by 5 is 10 so
the answer is when the current is 5
amperes the resistance will be equal to
10 ohms and we could write it like this
well I can ohms just like that
let's do one more one more the intensity
of light is inversely proportional so
the intensity of light is inversely
proportional to the now let's be careful
here to the square of the distance to
the square of the distance between the
light source and the object being
illuminated so let's just say let's say
that let's say well we could use I again
let's say I is equal to intensity
intensity of light and let's say that D
D I'll do it in a different color D is
equal D is equal to the distance between
between the light source light source
and object being illuminated and object
so that's what D the distance between
the light source and the object being
illuminated now what does this first
sentence tell us the intensity of the
light is inversely proportional so the
intensity of the light I is inversely
proportional so it's going to be some
proportionality constant times the
inverse times the inverse but notice the
intensity of light is inversely
proportional to the square of the
distance not just to the distance so to
the square of the distance so two
distance squared if it just said 2 the
distance we would just have a D here but
it says the intensity of light is
inversely proportional so 1 over the
square of the distance between the light
source and the object being illuminated
so that's what this first step statement
is going to give us this equation right
here now they tell us a light meter that
is 10 meters so they're saying when
distance is equal to 10 meters a light
meter that is 10 meters from a light
source registers 35 Lux so when the
distance is equal to 10 meters they're
telling us that the intensity the Lux is
a measure of intensity the intensity is
equal to 35 lux so what is the intense
what intensity would register 25 meters
from the light source so this first
statement they gave us that I'm wrote
down the information in this purple
color we can use that to solve for the
proportionality constant and then once
we have that constant we can solve for
AI or DS given one one or the other so
that statement told us they told us that
when D is equal to 10 I is equal to 35
so I is equal to 35 so 35 is equal to K
times 1 over d squared 1 over 10 squared
or we could say that 35 is equal to K
times 1 over 100 multiplied 10 squared
is just 100 multiply both sides of this
equation by 100 these cancel out and
we're left with K
is equal to what is this 3,500 3,500 so
we've solved we've used this statement
here where they gave us some values to
solve for our proportionality constant
so now we know that the equation is the
intensity is equal to 3,500 is equal to
3,500 that's K over R times 1 over d
squared or you can just write over d
squared now they say what intensity
would it register 25 meters from the
light source so they're saying D is 25
so intensity is equal to 3,500 divided
by divided by 25 squared our distance is
25 meters so the intensity the intensity
is going to be equal to 3,500 3,500
divided by well actually let's just keep
it simple let me see if this is this
well let's just this is divided by 25
times 25 that's 625 let's just to get
the calculator out so we get it's going
to be 3,500 divided by 25 times 25 which
is 625 which is equal to five point six
so it's equal to five point six Lux
which is the unit for light intensity
hopefully you found that useful